com cel a vento o merda cosa sai che
succede di anno quando la cosa ma perché
perché una volta ho perso ho detto cose
brutte ma bannato perna no 52 ore no non
ci voglio credere
è però fatto un account al volo tanto è
gratis rock ci siamo robbie fanizzi ma
cosa sto vedendo nella tabella bersani
va bene questa partita un e fermo
approfittiamo di spagna prova subito
subito ai anno telefonare in mezzo non è
in mezzo si ripreso mercato italiano da
vivaio del bro
peccato non ci sono per una parabola in
mezzo non è vero togli dalla vittoria da
li tira forte no ciccio c'è mattia che
hai fregato ti sei venduto già tanto
iniziata con minute neanche un secondo
le partita già abbiamo già ti sei
venduto va bene io almeno all 80
adesso lo scatto sulla riguarda però
solo di incazzato ma è proprio in mezzo
del mondo di mezzo per il mezzo pro
eccola lì eccola lì madonna togli la
mentina lato per favore non mi pare
preoccupare perfetto quello tenterà un
tiro a triplo ma non ci riesce
io riparto hi fi bru sei sono se sono
pro il pane varignana la butta dentro
ragazzi va bene bravo bravo pro così
meglio allora che la giornata signori
nonostante il ciccio si sia venduto agli
avversari sia per farci perdere tempo
per i video bannando sull'afasia
ferrarese vela tutte le notti prima
linea la ciccio farti perdonare tiene
aperta la ferma ferma
ho fatto il possibile ma l'ho pure
distrutto e stavo dicendo ogni volta che
la partita una partita nostra inizia
dobbiamo razionalizzare gli avversari
dobbiamo cercare di capire di che
nazionalità ford abusi nei cina poche
occhio che ti voglio tiro io la mia
santa 70 la breve famiglia bossi porti
sharing prendi questo è bellissima una
partita favignana rovi fan scelta quando
mai nell'universo 1 a 0 2 con del fare
attenzione questo bottinare e lo farà
mai
ma io ci sono
prova a ripartire però buono l'ha
toccata la toccata la facciata guardate
lo ha inglobato no forse no se non dato
che hanno ingrossato mia a scusami non
pensavo benissimo è rimasta là dove
lascia borotto carmela e non l'ha
giocata fa niente faccio io è un
pallonetto un po stramba realtà ci sta
perché la marina da porca vacca così col
toglierà ciccio no mammamia poi mi
chiamo paga guarda i cinesi potranno pur
avendo bravo veneti rocchi ha perdonato
sei già perdonato probabili gratis a
lavoro fatto fanizzi grazie grazie
non ti preoccupare mancando i minuti può
succedere quando io per favore bye bye
bye bye chiederà sempre bravissimo
position se non la rito che gol già
demonio bella buono buono
no ho solo organo veloce ofanto è
schizzato bussava ragazza al bello ha
detto è un cia utopici cos'è quanto alla
fine quanto l'ha spazzata forte la palla
rimane lì nonostante io abbia ben fatto
venti volte l'avversario attenzione è
pronto di ritirare muore ma come la
madonna tra lo svincolo e canavese mm
senso madonna billo a paolo a attenzione
position position che tenta di avanzare
io devo sfruttare in avanti non la
prendo la palla rimane lì
e allora non la prendo di nuovo roberto
fanizzi piero no la costa entrando sai
che entrava avviso desire di minchia che
tiro questa rimbalza male dipende come
mai avrò bella donna accusa gli ho tolto
perfetto come di partire per favore aver
per i partiti passa qualcuno porta bravo
vai
no se non guardo anch'io e campi l'ho
provato un babbo sono stato un babbo
no madonna cosa preso bravissimo cosa ha
preso il via la farina e sta spingendo
vari partiti io dio dio dio latino bella
una mina pazzesca che tiro e 4 a 0 le fa
vi c'è 40 43 però zero nel senso che sei
tu a 0 c cioè ti prego segna provider
forte
niente non riesco a toccare e provare
che tale demolito il gol e con loro mai
però non l'hanno non hanno non hanno
tirato bravo 10 secondi 987 no perfetto
dirà no no non abbiamo la forza anche
tutto sbagliato abbiamo aveva un casino
disastro è successo caselli non 4 ruolo
fatto ti prego allora mall ciccio la
prima è andata bene a posto mi sei
piaciuto ma secondo me puoi fare molto
di più alla posto spiegare il perché o i
comandi e roberto la macchina oberto il
suo nome sia ai anche fisico che sarebbe
la rom mi sento come lui avessi una
parte del corpo sua magari però non
posso dire no quello no possiamo dire
l'italia americani bravo bravo tocca di
nuovo e roberto felici
bravissimo come giochi oggi bravo
adesso mi stai piacere anzi è proprio
bravo che altro non giocavo in acqua non
so quindi butta o de picciotto monnalisa
beach ciò è di roberto fanizzi altro
versione la veste propri fan sì bravo ci
sembrò allora ti si merita cos'è che
c'hanno gli americani
noi gente un curry cosa anzi no così che
abbiamo noi che non hanno gli americani
poi avrete sicuramente in rete ma noi
abbiamo i pan di stelle
dobbiamo far dell'hard libro così ed ora
tutto si tratta quindi non postarsi
perfetto se vola se riesci se non fa
niente tira fanno gioco più bravo bravo
pro mannaggia roberto anche a 59 secondi
mi stai facendo soffrire
prendi questa seduta di duo d'attacco
incazzo crono è rimasta lì attenzione
oddio poi non ne andava per niente
perché l'autostrada
attenzione questo tira una ciofeca manor
ministro operativa di nuovo mi hanno fin
maledetti pezzi di non fare niente
avevano spinto mamma mia
allora la tiro io mai mi si aperto anche
il menu totalmente una botta che vi sia
aperto il tabellone un disastro ok
questa si stacca di nuovo aspetta se va
affinato riparto è ma che culo rimandare
veramente tutto positivo
che cacchio ora questo tireranno
è andata veramente di google ice mia ram
era rimbalzata precisa di andata quella
gli sta andando tutto bene è un peccato
abbiamo undici secondi non non sono
scontento perché l'abbiamo giocata
meglio noi perché hanno avuto più cool
in certe roba young avanti avanti ci sta
ci sta
da spazzino avanti un po scocciato molto
meglio è niente ci sta ci sta ci sta
cagni putin in essi ragazzi ci poteva
stare
peccato perché abbiamo giocata secondo
me è molto meglio però sono comunque
molto contento della partita mio
giocatore aveva poteva andare peggio
quindi sono contento però vi sia
piaciuto vi ringrazio e di aver visto il
video ringrazio anche il buon cibo ci
prenderemo la rivincita sugli stati
uniti ragazzi perché se invece si è
iscritti al canale e noi ci vediamo come
sempre anno prossimo video e ragazzi
[Musica]